[Applaudissements]
combattez regardez regardez si on
pouvait ou manier le cul j'avais dans
mon bateau restaurant
elle va me manquer il va me manquer
[Applaudissements]
c'est son dernier jour si on évite à il
a fait un travail exceptionnel sur la
chaîne son dernier jour où il va nous
manquer sachez le
xavier on sait pas encore ce que vous
allez faire sucer vous avez les
propositions de quoi coeur de de
kellogg's sais pas encore ce que vous
allez faire mais en tout cas vous allez
le faire vous avez vous avez quand même
retrouvé un boulot avant le costume
parce que ça peut m'aider peut-être
qu'on sait jamais en tout cas je
voudrais dire
xavier est un patron formidable et c'est
vrai que voilà il a et il a été très
présent à chaque fois et c'est vrai
qu'il a vu des choses ici formidable je
sais que vous ne serez plus jamais
déguisé en bourdon voilà si vous allez
sur tf1 embrasser ara aprikian si vous
allez sur m6 embrasser des andes m6 et
si vous allez sur equidia embrasser un
poney
merci
michel r